Evening.
We are back live for a bit.
Got a quick dinner. And now we are going
to make the uh neural MMO
neural net run and see. We can put it on
the website.
We will see what I do after that. If I
just do a short stream and call it or uh
if I start working on some other stuff.
But at the very least,
we'll uh we'll do that.
At the very least, we'll get this done
rather.
Okay.
So, the issue that I thought I had
resolved, but apparently not
appears to be right here.
This 16
89 thing,
I believe.
I believe that this should be
1817.
Now, this 128 I think is for the 128
comp channels.
I think that's what this is for. It's
been a long time since I've done
anything on this network.
But assuming that is the case
Oh, it's because the output dim of the
conve is supposed to be 128, right?
256.
Do we have 256 comp channels?
Did uh did I do that without really
noticing?
See,
and for context here, what's going on?
Um we trained a neural net in PyTorch
with Puffer Lib. Uh, we trained it for
12,000 years worth of data. It's like
something ridiculous. Over 300
terabytes, 600 some odd billion steps.
Uh, it did very very well. And now I
want everybody to be able to play with
it. So in order to put it onto the
website, we're porting the neural net to
pure C. So I can load the trained
weights into C and then I can compile
that to web assembly and run it online.
And hopefully we'll be able to play with
that online very soon. As soon as I fix
this,
right, so something is definitely odd
here because
I get all the map is 256dimensional.
which I don't think that makes sense to
me.
This is map 2D of map buff,
So next
we have to recompile this
B
- 256
I don't really have a way to check as
is.
So, so far
this is an exact
match.
Okay.
So somewhere this must have gotten
messed up. I would assume yes.
I do 255
match exactly. Okay. Do 256
7 88.
Yep. This matches exactly.
Okay.
And now
another good one, 1800.
Ah, that's different.
I see.
Okay. So, I think it's the reward that
somehow is different. H,
that's weird.
Definitely weird.
Oh, wait.
B offset plus I.
Yeah. No, this is fine.
because
I never said it. It looks like
and then this should be net project
buffer.
three.
So now it looks like this at least has a
chance to match.
So we will encode this
and then we will uh
If this is not a bot message, say hello
again.
48. Perfect.
This matches
match here.
209.
Lovely.
All right. So, so far now this matches.
Uh, so now
this has to go through layerorm.
I'm actually going to kill this one.
down to here.
Actually, one up. We go here,
77. Yes. Welcome, Snowy.
Yep,
I am. And let's ban that other guy
because that guy was a bot.
Get rid of this.
Not banan you by mistake. Okay, there we
go.
Thinking to read your thesis. I might
learn a thing or two. That thing will be
very, very long and very boring. Um,
academic papers are just not going to be
particularly fun to read. Uh if you want
here if you want to like get something
something in like a much more condensed
form, my thesis video is on YouTube and
it did quite well.
So apparently people find it
entertaining.
Okay.
163k views.
So this is an hour and then after that
if you want to learn some stuff about
reinforcement learning
quick start guide,
not this one.
Uh where is it? Quick start guide here.
Yeah. What's the difference between your
thesis and the video? The video is my
thesis defense.
The thesis as in the manuscript
is 170 bloody pages.
Man, much of which is highly repetitive
because all of my work is around the
same topic of neural MMO.
You can read the abstract if you want
though because
it's kind of funny. the environment can
process totaling uh 3,000
agent steps per second. So in the six
months after my PhD, I made the new
version of neural MMO which can process
about 1.5 million agent steps per
second,
which is literally
500 times faster.
So
yeah, there's been some progress.
PhD thesis are usually not particularly
interesting.
I like to read the pages that covered
your journey. Yeah, those are fine. I
kind of wrote those like for the thesis,
the things in between it to kind of like
outline the story of it.
I mean, this is a project. I literally
started this I tried to start Nurmo in
high school and I didn't know what I was
doing. And then I tried it again my
freshman year of undergrad and I didn't
know what I was doing. And then I tried
it again my sophomore and uh sophomore
year and it caught on. And then I ended
up working on that and I took it to
OpenAI and then I took it to MIT and I
worked on it for like another five years
and it mostly worked but not quite and
then I finally in the last year I've
gotten it to work. So I mean it's really
been like a seven eight year journey at
this point and now it works and the
model that I am uh implementing right
now is the conclusive proof uh that the
thing that I wanted to do works.
So, it's really just in the last few
days that we've gotten a crazy crazy
result on this
Looks like it works.
Let's see.
Nope. Not smart.
Something's happened to them.
PhD people also have classes
kind of.
We had to take like four classes that
really weren't relevant to anything I
did and then a couple of electives.
That's it. You mostly do research.
Benefit Georgia Tech online MS.
I'm right to understand the project like
an AI playing a game. It's a lot more
than that because
the technology that is used in this
enables an AI to do a lot more than play
games. I mean this fundamentally helps
us uh to create artificial multi- aent
intelligence.
But yes, the form that it takes is the
form of a game.
Now, this thing is clearly not working
the way that it's supposed to be
working. I can show you how it's
supposed to look.
Not this one. We actually have slightly
better than this.
There we go.
And uh let me get rid of this
breakpointed
on tic-tac-toe.
Yeah, of course.
turnbased games are slightly more
irritating just uh there's a little bit
of engineering involved but yes very
easily
typically what we do is we do um
we we prefer just for the infrastructure
it's better when you have moves games
where you can evaluate all the moves at
the same time but that has nothing to do
with the uh the learning itself that's
just simply the infrastructure being a
little easier
Yeah. So, this is how it's supposed to
look. Um,
so this thing has learned to play this
game just by playing the game.
I didn't tell it anything about the
rules of the game or really anything
else.
It's kind of just had to figure it out
on its own.
And it's playing this game with a
thousand other AIs in it.
You can see on the hot bar that it has
equipment.
There's actually a market where it can
buy and sell stuff. Um, there is a prof
like profession. It needs to like
equipped harvesting tools to pick up
resources, armor and weapons and like
consumables,
all sorts of stuff.
That's one of them. Yes.
I think more generally
my the reason I do this stuff is because
like multi-agent interaction is really
this fundamental part of intelligence
and um it trickles into so many
different random industrial processes.
To give you some examples, right, we're
looking at like autonomous driving
stuff. We're looking at like planning
based problem around autonomous driving.
We're looking at construction stuff.
We're looking at drones. Like there just
lots and lots of different problems
where this stuff is applicable
immediately without really having to
change very much at all from the formats
in here. It's a very general purpose
tech.
But the thing is it never really worked
before because it just it took so many
years to get it to the point where it
works this well.
It's learned to play. Is Is it also
improving? It's not improving now while
I'm running it here, but over the whole
course of when I was training it, it
basically it played this game for I it
took me like a few days to train this
model. But in those few days, it played
12,000 years worth of games. And uh this
model is better than me at the game. And
I wrote the game.
It's very very precise with its movement
and it like it understands exactly where
it can and cannot stand. The higher
level intelligence bits are still
difficult. So like it doesn't have like
a it doesn't seem like it has like a
cohesive game plan of what it's going to
do, but in the moment to moment it is
way better than I am at the game and
it's figured that out without me. It
can't even see these pixels
like the pixels the rendering here. This
is here for our sake. It basically just
gets to see a big block of numbers.
Possible to record its current move set,
train on them in the background. If you
do that, if you just record the move
set, it's not going to get any better
because it already knows how to produce
its current move set. What it needs to
know, right, is it needs to see like
events in the game. So, it needs to see
like when it levels up, it needs to see
like when it dies. Things like that are
the signals that it uses to figure out
how to improve its gameplay
somewhat. Yes,
somewhat.
In the case of this game only,
uh, with just the current text,
it can't really see what's going on as
clearly as it should be able to. Just
like the way that we're presenting it,
the data from the game, uh, it makes it
very difficult for it to know exactly
what's going on. like it has some idea
but it's very difficult for it to see as
clearly as we can see it here. So I
think just by improving that this would
do a lot better.
It's kind of funny here like you see
it's like oh no it's getting hit. That's
bad. But the thing is it knows that that
specific enemy is so weak that it can't
do any damage to it. It's basically it
doesn't play exactly like a human would.
it like it doesn't care that it's
getting hit because it's like really not
doing anything to it. Like see
it's funny
like we hit improve.
Yes, but like it's that's not exactly
how it maps into the code.
You don't want to show it pixels.
A really naive way of putting it would
be like the thing doesn't have great
eyesight would be like a really naive
way to put it.
Yes, I know exactly how to do it as
well. I just haven't done it yet because
since I graduated, this is not the only
thing I've worked on. You know, I've
worked on so so many things around this
tech. Um, I kind of did this thing in
like a few months, maybe like three,
two, three months, and then I really
haven't touched it very much since,
except that occasionally I come back and
I train it. I run the training on it
just to see how our latest learning
algorithm does.
And so far this thing has done quite
well.
Yeah, like right there it's kiting. It
literally just learned a method to uh it
learned a method to fight while taking
no damage
I mean there are things that you can do
that are directly helpful like when
you're pretty new but yeah some of the
problems that we're solving in this
project are really really cutting edge
things
and this is really the only place where
this type of stuff is going on in
reinforcement learning at the moment.
Why'd you open source it though? To
improve science.
I figure I can make uh I can make enough
money in the field regardless, right? I
don't think open sourcing something
makes it less valuable necessarily.
Companies see um companies see the work
that we've done and a few of them hire
us to help with their reinforcement
learning efforts.
Yeah, let's figure out what the heck is
going on with this.
Yeah,
I would say so.
I would definitely say so.
Can you streaming and teaching bits? Uh,
my content, some of it ends up being
educational, though that's not really
the primary goal of what I'm doing,
right? The stream is for the most part
like I just do all this research live
and then people that are interested and
want to learn can like join in and pitch
in to the project and learn by uh learn
by doing.
What I'm mostly trying to do at the
moment, it's a combination of things.
One is I'm trying to improve the
fundamental learning algorithms in the
field. Two, I'm trying to make it easier
to build simulations for a variety of
applications. And three, I'm trying to
go directly to people in industry now uh
to solve hard problems using this tech
that I've built.
it be fun to have an FPS shooter end?
Yes, it would. That's kind of hard from
a simulation perspective, but actually I
have uh there's a guy I know that has
one that is very good. Uh it's sort of a
different architecture just because you
have to do a bunch of raycasts. So, it's
better to simulate that on the GPU than
the CPU. Um but yeah, there's a guy uh
Brennan Shackleton who just finished his
his PhD at Stamford um who's built a
very cool environment for that. Curious,
what is your current funding source? Uh
I mean some of it's personal stuff, but
also like we do have clients, right? We
have a couple of companies that pay for
uh essentially extended support and also
deliverables around our library.
So that's what we're doing at the
moment. And then going forward since
this new release has made our tech so
much better, we're going to start
looking for like larger fixed
deliverable contracts in reinforcement
learning. So the idea is there are folks
in industry that are trying to get
reinforcement learning working on
specific problems. It's very difficult.
We have very advanced methods and tools
and we can do a lot of that work for
these companies. Now
must be rich bra. I mean this stuff
doesn't cost like anywhere near as much
as the rest of AI. Like our training
runs so fast, you can literally do a lot
of these training runs on your laptop.
Like let me show you something.
All right, this is Breakout.
So obviously this thing is not playing
the game at all, right? This is just a
random neural network. It's just
pressing random buttons. This is how
fast I can train it just on my desktop.
Okay. So, this thing is going to take
about 30 seconds and in those 30 seconds
it is going to uh press 100 million
buttons.
So, at first it's going to press random
buttons
but then as it sees what happens in the
game it'll learn to play it. And now
literally by the time I will have
finished the sentence, the thing will
have learned to play the game a lot
better than I can play it.
If it just finishes its evaluation, it
does a little evaluation at the end.
Desktop.
So this is not something that's entirely
new, right? Reinforcement learning has
existed before now, but the difference
is that stuff like this used to take
hours or days.
It takes 30 seconds now to do this. So,
we've just massively sped everything up.
Can explain or share the algorithm.
You'd have to read the uh the quick
start guide. It's proximal policy
optimization with a bunch of fancy
modifications. Um
the core algorithm it's an application
of gradient descent to uh policy
improvement which is to say you're
trying to take step you're trying to
adjust the weights of a neural network
in a way that lead to actions that
improve the score.
I remember like 2018 doing this was a
longunning project.
what breakout
because I've been doing my main thing
since 2018 as well. I mean this is the
the main result that I have right from
recently is this.
So this does not train in 30 seconds.
This trains in 3 to 4 days and it trains
not just on a desktop. It trains on a
6GPU server but still like this type of
thing used to take a thousand GPUs. So a
heck of a lot better.
RL. Yeah. I mean, I've been doing RL
since at least 2018. Um,
a lot of people kind of just gave up on
it, but the thing is like I didn't and
we actually have it working incredibly
well now. It's pretty exciting. Is
training the bottleneck or environment
steps? Training is the bottleneck. And
the only reason that training is the
bottleneck is because of how fast our
simulations run. This simulation here
runs up to 1.5 million steps per second
per CPU core. So we can on a 32 core
server, we can literally generate tens
of millions of steps of data per second.
So it's just never the bottleneck. It's
always the GPU
training itself takes a lot of time for
RL. Uh for this thing it does. For most
of our environments it doesn't. So, like
here's another one.
Look. So, here is a random neural
network trying to fly a drone. It's
terrible at it. This is a four motor
drone just submitted to us. This
environment was coded by some undergrads
who just submitted this environment to
us.
I'd say don't hold your breath, but you
probably can because it'll be done by
the time you run out of air.
Can you optimize the algorithm more? Do
you think C plays a role if it's coded
in that it's performant? Uh, we can
definitely optimize the algorithm more,
but the thing is like regardless, it
benefits us to have the simulator in C
because it just lets us run more
experiments and iterate faster. Like
we've made fundamental algorithm
advances and we wouldn't have been able
to do that if the environments weren't
fast because we would have to have a
thousand servers to do our experiments.
I don't have a thousand servers. I've
got like 10 and that's enough.
H100s are not faster for R out. Funny
enough, H00s are about the same speed as
4090s.
It's pretty funny, but that tends to be
the case. You can technically get them
up to 2x faster if you really try, but
it's kind of a pain. And they're like 20
grand versus two grand. So,
okay, let's take a look at this drone.
So, yeah, that took like 30 seconds to
train. And there, it can fly a drone
now. And this is individually
controlling the four motors, like the
four uh propellers that the quadcopter
would have. There you go.
And leave it for a month.
You actually can train this stuff on a
1650, no problem. It'll take like one or
two minutes instead of 30 seconds.
But that's it. Like other than that,
it'll just work.
This is the cool thing now, right? Is
you actually you can actually do real
experiments. Now, I do have some
servers. Like, if you look behind me on
the wall here,
I don't know if you can see with the
camera, I have, I believe, eight or nine
desktops and then two multiGPU servers.
We have a total of, I believe, 20 4090s
and then 15090 for our research.
Does it use images to train? No, we
don't use images by default. We can use
images, but it's much slower. So, we
like to do a partially observe local
state. Did you do a poker playing bot? I
have not. I've been tempted to because
my father plays a ton of poker and I
think it would be kind of funny to make
a good bot for it. It's apparently quite
a hard problem. I don't understand why
it's a hard problem, but it would
definitely be a cool thing to do.
If I contribute to Puffer AI and make
some contributions, it means I've
learned something. Yes, of course. I'd
be scared to see the electricity bills.
It's not that bad. Like each machine if
you run it like full throttle is only
going to be like a kilowatt. So 15 cents
an hour. And if I were to rent a machine
it would be a dollar or two an hour. So
it's like a tenth of the price of
renting that. So it's not that bad.
Like this model, this neural MMO model
right here. This took me three to four
days on 64090s.
So that would probably be
around like $1,000 of compute if I were
to rent it out, like if I had to rent
those machines. But because of this, it
was like, I don't know, you know, maybe
$20 of electricity, something like that.
Maybe maybe 20 to 50. still way way way
less than if I'd rented them.
We also do give access to these
machines. Uh we give contributors access
to these machines. So people that like
keep coming back and doing good work, we
give them one of the boxes to use for
development. Give them access.
This is all like the goal is to really
just have a big open source RL effort to
make the field fast and sane and make
this tech just work.
So I'm curious as to why this is not Oh,
I know why this isn't working. This
isn't working because I'm dumb.
I forgot to comment this out.
Okay.
Neural net running in pure C. No
PyTorch, no fancy uh no fancy deep
learning frameworks. Pure C.
Let's see if it's smart.
I have no idea how stable this is going
to be.
And the reason I have no idea how stable
this is going to be is because um well,
I haven't tested it at all.
Oh, it really wants that shovel.
It doesn't know how to get the shovel
without dying.
Oh, that's funny.
Yeah, this is a way better model than I
had before, though. Holy crap.
Awesome.
You got to fight somebody at some point,
man. What are you doing?
It doesn't want to fight because it's
low health, though.
[Music]
I mean, fair enough. I wouldn't know how
to get out of that situation either
there. I'd probably just run away and go
find somebody else, but then I would
have run into that level 32 and gotten
one shot.
Yeah, you shouldn't have taken that hit
there.
I don't know how much health it needs to
defeat a level one.
Don't take a hit there.
Okay.
Can it play Legend of Zelda NES? We had
somebody that was working on that. So,
we have somebody who's beaten the entire
game of Pokemon Red uh using well
reinforcement learning and using some of
our tools in Puffer Lib. It's a project
that we sponsored compute for as well.
Um, so the problem with Zelda isn't so
much that it's like super super hard to
learn necessarily. It's just that the uh
the game runs pretty slow. Like it runs
a 100 times slower at least than this
game here. So that just means it doesn't
mean it's any harder per se. It just
means that you'd need a hundred times
more servers to learn it properly just
because it's slow. Um, so you can do it
and in fact it's very easy to set up
training and it's probably not that hard
to at least get an agent that like does
something in the first level pretty
reasonably.
But getting something that actually
plays the whole game really well, it
just takes a lot of compute. So a lot of
the research that I do, right, we use
these fast environments because I can
run way more experiments uh on the
resources that I have on something
that's super fast and then I can
directly use those algorithmic
innovations on things that are slower
where things get more expensive. Right?
That's kind of how I look at stuff.
Okay, let's see. He's got a tool. Let's
see if this one can go find some armor.
Gotten some gems. Gems are okay. They're
not super useful. He's got a bow. Is he
going to go pick up that medicine? Yes.
Okay.
I saw I think I saw an ore at the bottom
of the screen. I don't think it saw it,
though. Okay. Lots of medicine. Cool.
Oh,
it's healing. Holy. I've never been able
to pull that off.
So, what it just did is it consumed
three healing items in the middle of
combat in order to defeat something that
it should absolutely not been able to
defeat. It defeated a level six.
Is the motive different for every game?
In research, sometimes. It depends. We
do some stuff just because it's cool.
Uh, and then we do some stuff because it
fundamentally teaches us uh ways to
improve the algorithm. So for instance,
this is an incredibly hard task. If
stuff works here, it pretty much works
everywhere. Uh we have easier tasks that
are just really quick to run. So like if
we just want to get a rough idea of
something is useful, we have a bunch of
these like faster to learn environments
that we use. And then we have these more
academic tasks like mazes and things
that are designed to test memory and
test exploration. We have a whole bunch
of different tasks we use for different
things that learn the recipes for items.
There are not recipes in this game. Uh
what there is is uh there's a tool
hierarchy. So there are tiers one
through five of equipment and uh there's
also tier one through five harvesting
tools. And the way that you get the
harvesting tools is by beating stronger
and stronger agents. And then you have
to equip the harvesting tools and go
pick up find in the world and pick up
the higher tier equipment. And there's
also a market where they can buy and
sell items with each other.
said it's multi- aent, meaning there are
other AIs in the game. Is there
something like that there's a main AI
which has to be prioritized?
No, they're all independent. But all the
AIS are independent. And actually, it's
kind of funny. One thing that I've seen
is they'll try to steal kills from each
other. So like the person who lands the
last blow gets the XP. So like they'll
try to steal the last hit from each
other. It's kind of funny. Go-to
application for this would be Stardew.
Um,
Stardo is kind of just like a chill
farming game, right?
That's just my teammates. Yeah, Stardo
is kind of like a chill farming game,
you know? It's like, could you set up
something to play Stardew Valley?
Probably. Uh, it would help if the game
weren't so slow, right? But like,
probably. Um,
I don't know.
I'll show you the next project that I'm
going to be working on since this is a
sufficient test for this. Uh, unless
it's stuck here. Is it stuck here? No.
Okay. So far, this AI, it seems like
this is just playing perfectly fine for
quite a good while here.
And see, like it was letting the level
one hit it because the level one doesn't
do any damage. And that was just
unlucky.
It ran up and there just happened to be
a super high level agent there that
one-shot it.
Nothing you can do about that.
Cool though.
Training time directly proportional. I
will show you the graph for this because
it is quite crazy.
So it's just a normal looking curve. But
the thing is this xaxis is in hundreds
of billions. So this is 640
billion training steps which is equal to
over 12,000 years of games played.
So as you can see it's not directly
proportional. You get most of the
learning early on and then it's kind of
like this slow linear growth and then it
levels off at the end
which to be fair I don't even know if it
would fully level off at the end because
like there are techniques we do that
kind of make it like expected that it
levels off at the end. So possibly we
could train it for much longer. I don't
know.
Doesn't that mean the human brain is
crazy smart? It means the human brain
has had the benefit of millions of years
of evolution. These do not have the
benefit of millions of years of
evolution.
Humans are basically hardwired
to understand a bunch of stuff basically
out of the box. It's really hard to
build that into an algorithm.
Like basically when when you look at
this game, okay, when you look at this
game, when you look at this drone or you
look at this game,
like you already know what's going on,
like immediately, right, without ever
having played it. The AI doesn't
understand anything. It's like if I were
to random if I were to completely put
randomass graphics here that make no
sense and then have you play it. That's
kind of analogous to what the RL does.
So like in some ways reinforcement
learning is super human uh at learning
like difficult patterns. But when those
patterns match with human intuition then
humans are much better.
Can you resume with different words?
Uh, you kind of can. Yes, you can at
least bootst like you can warm start it
for sure. Like you can do stuff with the
weights.
I mean I'll open source the weights as
well. Why not?
If anyone wants to play with them.
pretty happy. Oh yeah, I'm going to show
you the process of putting this on the
website as well because uh it's pretty
cool how easy it is to get this to be
like on the site.
I mean, I better be passionate, man. I
literally this is all I do. I do this
and I work out. That's pretty much it.
Actually, this is kind of like the least
engaged I've been in a while because
like releases are just not fun. I've
been doing a whole bunch of boring
release work, but uh it's basically
done. We pretty much like there are like
maybe one or two last little things to
check, but we can pretty much just
release it and uh that means I get to do
so much new cool work. Like there's so
much new cool stuff I can do. Hope
you'll succeed and even and find more
people. Oh yeah. I mean here, let me
show you. So this is one of the coolest
things that I'm most proud of actually
about this project. So actually let me
show you the new docs page so you really
get a sense of the scale because the
current one is six months outdated.
Okay, these are all the environments
that we have in Popper Lab. I've written
like five of these. The rest of these
are from contributors, most of whom are
people who came in with zero
reinforcement learning experience and
kind of just thought that this stuff was
cool and wanted to learn and then stuck
with it for a bit.
This was a new contributor. Uh, this was
a new contributor who also did this one,
this one, this one, and like a couple
more down here. These were a couple of
undergrads who are brand new. Um,
let's see. These two were me. This one
was somebody who was brand new to both
RL and even programming. These two were
by a new contributor in the last few
weeks. Uh, this one was by a new
contributor. Each of these was by
somebody new and different.
Yeah. So, there's like maybe 10
different people at this point.
And Gock, what is that?
I have no idea what that is. That a
ligma.
bit much. Like technically brand new
programmers can get involved with this
stuff and we've had a couple people do
that. It's quite difficult. You really
have to want to do it. Uh if you do have
some programming background though, then
it's pretty straightforward to get into
it.
Like the people who are going to have
the easiest time with Puffer Lib are
people who've done at least a little bit
of low-level dev. Just like a little bit
of low-level dev. Then you'll have a
decent enough time.
All right. Here I I said I was going to
show how you put this on the website. So
this is the super cool thing because it
is written in pure C and because we can
put the neural nets in pure C as well.
We can compile this thing directly to
Web Assembly without having to rewrite
the whole bloody thing in horrible
JavaScript
MSDK.
Now puffer export. No puffer.
Ah, this one.
Building for web deployment.
Uh-huh. And now,
oops, my watch is dead. Let me plug this
in.
Boom.
And now
if I just relaunch this website.
I think I have to go here so that it'll
uh it'll refresh.
Now if I do this,
I don't know why this screen is the
wrong size. Let me fix that. I don't
like that.
* 15
then times 11
960 by 704.
Okay. So I somehow I messed this up
completely.
This should have been
960 by 70.
Is it always going to be the same thing
on here?
I might want to get a different speed if
it is
cuz I don't like having an agent that
starts all the way at the side.
there. I the thing is I don't actually
know if that's going to do it correctly
because mcript in randomness is weird
but
here
be like this.
Okay, we're somewhere different. And if
I click it again.
Yeah, we're somewhere different.
It got almost one shot by uh this thing
as soon as it spawned.
It's actually funny cuz this thing knows
how to write to fight extremely well,
but until you have a sword, you kind of
just need some help if you want to
fight. It's like, what do I do? I got
hit. I got hit for 90% of my HP as soon
as I spawned. I kind of just have to run
around for a bit until my HP regens.
I'll show you what a human looks like
playing this in a in a second. I just
want to see what this guy does. Plus, I
haven't watched this for very long since
I uploaded the policy. I want to make
sure it's stable
and like it's mostly doing reasonable
stuff. Probably shouldn't have taken a
hit there, but not a huge deal.
Oh
yeah, level 29.
Level seven is too high level. It can't
kill that. Level 10. It can't kill any
of those.
Yeah, I think it's screwed here.
Yeah, I can't. It's just It's pinned in.
All right, I'll show you I'll show you
what a human looks like playing this
thing.
Hang on.
Okay, I'm playing it now. Let me die
real quick so I can play it from the
start.
Okay, so
I have to find Your goal is to find like
a level one to three maybe to fight.
Okay, so I found this guy. I can fight
him.
I put this I equip this thing.
Get that medical herb.
Get this gem for style points.
That is a level 17. I don't want to go
near that.
Okay, we get a sword
and a helmet.
I would like some boots.
Oh, there's also medical herbs down
there.
I'll get some herbs.
Uh, that level 36 is scary.
I don't even want to go over there with
the level 36.
Yeah, they can run or they can walk. The
enemies cannot. The enemies cannot run.
The enemies can only walk. This level
nine's too strong, even with the armor.
I can kill the level five.
Uh, and I also want that equipment down
there. Let me get this guy out of the
way.
I can try. I don't think I can kill the
level nine, though.
So, it's a little difficult. I actually
think I should walk here because I don't
want to run into a high level and not
have time to react.
take my sword off, put my tool on, and I
get a set of boots. Perfect. Now I have
a full set of level one armor.
Uh, so now I'm a little bit more
confident, maybe, but I still don't
think I can kill the level 9.
That's a level three. That's perfect.
Okay, now I'm level
level three
and then I think that this guy gives me
XP, right? Yeah. So now I'm level four.
I'm getting slightly
more confident.
Uh that level 11 will kill me.
Okay. But I do have some medicinal
herbs.
So I think I can fight maybe up to like
a level eight.
10 is going to be too strong
unless I I could try the cheese.
It's quite difficult to do it correctly,
but okay, I did it.
And now I get the tier two.
So with this, I should be able to get
some good stuff.
Oh, shoot. Can I not equip that? Oh, I
forgot that I messed up the action
space. You can't equip from this slot. I
forgot about that bug. Oh, that's
unfortunate.
Dang,
that's a big mess up. All right. Well, I
guess I have to uh
Yeah, that sucks.
I guess I have to go find
somebody else to fight. Level four
doesn't give me anything and the other
ones will kill me.
Level five. That's level nine.
Okay.
Level six. Oh, that's actually good. So,
V one sell this. Pick up this.
Oh, maybe there wasn't a bug. Can I just
not equip it? I think I'm just not high
level. Hang on.
Oh, no. I'm good. I can actually get it.
Perfect. So,
I have to I'm out of slots here.
I think I have to consume one herb.
Okay, this is too high tier. I forget
what it looks like, but there is there's
a higher level ore
and there's a higher level uh bow,
but I don't know which one it is I
should be able to get. Those are tier
ones. I don't care about those.
Uh let's see.
Okay, I think it's the silver one.
Yes, it is. So, we can take this off. We
can put this on.
We can sell this.
Take this off. Put this on. This guy's
coming for me. I don't like that.
Okay.
So, I now have
Oh, I'm dumb. I sold the wrong one.
Whoops.
Uh, that is a level 36. That will that
will instantly kill me.
Get this gem.
I think I can just kill this thing
without even a weapon on, right? Yeah.
Okay. Oh, that would actually be quite
good, though. I think this sword.
No, that's too high level.
Like, you actually have to really hunt
for gear in this. It's kind of like the
MMO. It was sort of meant to be like the
MMO gear grind where you have to like
find gear.
It's a level 17. So, the level 15s and
above have ranged weapons. That's why
they're kind of scary.
Like this guy has a ranged weapon down
there
and uh it will do a lot of damage.
If I like the one way that you can kind
of die by accident is if you just run
into a level 30 off screen. Like they
can kind of just one-shot you from the
edge of the screen.
I still don't have a bow.
I think I've checked this entire lake
though.
Uh, we'll get the blue one because I
don't know. I like it.
Oh, that's the bow. Okay. I forgot what
it looked like in my own game. Duh.
I should be able to like go exploring a
little bit more here with this bow
because I think I can kill everything up
to level 15 with this.
it's just way it's like really easy to
kite with a bow.
So yeah, there's meant to be like tech
in this game as well.
Like you can kite like this if you're uh
it's a little tricky to do, but you can
kite like this.
It only works up to level 14 though.
This guy can just die instantly. Who
cares?
And the only other thing I would kind of
like is a sword.
Uh that's a level 22. I don't want
anything to do with him.
Oh, level seven. Perfect.
Okay, so now I'm level eight
I think that I might be able to pick up
these.
Uh, I'd prefer not to have to consume.
I'll get rid of this low-level sword.
Okay,
so now we're uh we're pretty well off, I
think. Uh I only have one piece of level
two gear,
but
maybe it's good enough. We'll see. Sword
does a lot of damage. That
level 34 very scary. I mean, you can see
why this thing is like kind of tricky,
right? Because basically, if you if
you're not paying attention for a
second, you can get one shot by the high
levels and you can also get like boxed
in by like several lower levels if
you're not careful.
And also like they'll come fight you
when you're like in the middle of trying
to pick up equipment as well.
Okay, so there's a level 16 there.
I think I can fight it. I don't know.
It's kind of sketchy, honestly.
I'm gonna try it for the content
and also because I don't want to be
playing this game all night.
H, it one shot me. Okay. Well, there you
go. Apparently, you need to have level
two gear if you want to fight something
that high level. And if I just hit
control
Yeah, if I just hit control, I'm no
longer playing it. Now the neural net's
playing it.
So there you go. That is the neural MMO
3 demo.
And that is also my test that it works
well for the website.
I'm quite happy with that.
What's next?
I think we actually get to start on the
next thing.
Yeah, we'll show you the next crazy
thing.
It's going to take me just a second to
go grab
the policy for this.
So, this is a short set of 59
experiments that I ran to try to find
some good settings for this specific
other environment I'm about to show you.
Um,
what do I like the shape of?
Kind of like the shape of
this one. Maybe.
Yeah, this one's good.
So all I I have to do here
is
I have to grab the settings of this
environment
and I have to put them into the
configuration file for this.
And then you'll see this will be a this
is a thousand agent uh battle
environment with like drones and planes
and stuff.
Looks like kind of a slow setting
though. We'll see.
frame.
So these settings need to be copied.
And I should automate this process, but
I haven't bothered. So I do it manually
for now.
It's not that many settings.
A few numbers.
Modern 3D games.
Uh, I don't know. You This was kind of
3D. You'll see.
These are kind of crazy settings.
Well, I don't know how good these will
be, but we'll start with them.
Hopefully this does like something
interesting.
2 minutes. Not terrible. We'll see if
this learns anything.
Let me see what number we were supposed
to expect on this.
getting score in the threes.
Oh.
Huh.
Well, it's learn to do something weird.
I don't know what.
Huh.
it's possibly just found some like weird
quirk with the environment. We'll see.
I don't think you need to train it this
long. Like
We have all that nicely stored. This is
almost done. And this looks like it's
learned something.
I have absolutely no idea what this is
going to look like though.
they doing anything?
But just reset.
Yeah, these ones are flying into the
ground, so that's not great.
I mean, these ones are like fanning out
at least in a reasonable way.
Yeah. Like these actually look like
armies.
Oh, yeah. There's battle going on up
there. Hang on.
Yeah, their laser's going off. So,
they're fighting up all the way up high
in the sky.
I like
Oh, this is how you do it. Yeah. Okay. I
just forgot my own controls.
Yeah. So they're fighting up here.
I don't know why these ones are just
like pouring into the ground like that.
Kind of disappointing.
But there are some proper battles.
I think this is what I'm going to work
on for most of tomorrow. They're
dipping. They don't want to fight. Yeah,
but I don't They don't get penalized for
dying. I intentionally did that so that
they wouldn't just like [ __ ] out.
And then the when they all disappear
like that, it's just the environment
resetting.
Okay. Okay. I mean, this is cool, right?
Here we actually have battle going on on
the ground.
only one wins. So, the thing is, it's
way harder to teach
it's way harder to teach the agents to
like make their team win than it is to
teach them to like go get a ton of
kills, which is kind of going to produce
the same result.
just out of technicalities.
I think that this probably I'm going to
start working on that environment all
day tomorrow.
Time is at 8:00 p.m.
Can you fine-tune it in a way that only
one agent remains? You can. And from a
learning perspective, there's nothing
difficult there. In practice, we prefer
not to remove agents during training. Uh
we prefer to just like respawn them
somewhere else.
And the reason for that has nothing to
do with the learning algorithm. It just
has to do with how the infrastructure uh
like puts data together.
The thing that's a little disappointing
is it's not like this is obviously
massively better.
like none of these get like zero
collision, right?
what the model can do and what's tough
to achieve.
Um,
CS:GO definitely,
PUBG probably a fair bit harder.
Uh, I mean, the main difficulty with all
of those is just like the infrastructure
to get a ton of like you basically need
to run a thousand plus copies of the
game minimum. Uh, and you need to do it
fast. So, like
that's the tough part.
Which is why we have all these super
fast environments where we do that
easily for research purposes.
You train the neural net for each
environment. The thing that you have to
manually adjust
uh is usually just the data format and
then the way the rewards are presented.
Like as you've seen, right, the fact
that you have to train on each
environment doesn't matter when you
train super fast.
Okay, let's see. Let's see if this is
like more,
right?
Fact.
Are there any other competitors?
Uh, not that can not who can do what we
do.
I don't know. I really don't think about
competitors very much in general. I
think it's kind of lame.
Like beating the next guy to a quick
buck is like lame to me as a mindset.
I think a lot more about like
fundamental technical advances that
would like make a bunch of cool stuff
happen.
I don't know. Everyone always asks me
about competitors. I'm like, I don't
freaking know. I don't really care
though.
Like I guess in my mind like what's more
interesting waking up in the morning
like yeah I got to beat that other
schmuck or like yeah I gotta make some
freaking awesome sci-fi tech right
that's how I look at at
least.
I got plenty of things to worry about on
the tech side, man. I have plenty of
things to worry about, but
competition ain't one of them.
Okay, so these parameters at least look
more reasonable to me.
I don't know if they are actually
better, but these like look better to
me.
You're not going to like the way that we
do ours if you're doing TypeScript
stuff. Um,
you could basically make everything
except the web assembly stuff for our
website with like '90s tech.
It's literally like HTML and CSS. That's
it.
I don't know. I like we keep things very
simple whenever we can.
Like even all these Sims, right? These
Sims could be like a giant nightmare of
C++,
but like they're actually just really
really simple and basic C.
I like simple things. I don't like
complicated things.
all the big tech engineers always bug me
like oh can we do it in C++ as well it's
like can but don't tell me I didn't warn
you
understood what's the meaning yeah but
then they say oh you just have to be
better in order to understand it and
it's like well If I can write the same
thing shorter and faster and simpler,
that's actually the better thing.
Yeah. So, this is a way better policy. I
can tell here.
And the way I can tell is by how it's
training super stably
and the collision rate being a lot
lower.
Now, it seems like at the very end it
messed up a little bit, but
it did mess up a little at the end, but
we'll see.
C is the best. I mean, you can get the
same performance in C++ or whatever, but
like C is effortlessly the best. Like,
if you just want something to be fast
and not have to think about it like that
much, like C is fast by default and you
have to be stupid to make it slow.
Whereas like other languages are slow by
default and you have to be clever to
make them fast.
Okay, this policy looks more reasonable
to me.
I actually think I want to train it for
only 40 mil cuz I think it sort of
collapsed at the end.
Hey uh bet. We got the neural MMO policy
working on the website.
I had to fix layer norm and some stuff.
I have deer outside eating the apples
off my apple trees.
They get any closer, I'm going to go out
there and get me a venison steak.
I don't want these things. My apples.
Those are mine.
H Okay. So, it's not that it's unstable.
It's that when you evalid it actually
gets worse.
What happens if I do?
We'll just do We'll put it back in, I
guess.
Oh, yeah. Don't they have like horrible
pry diseases
here?
They have they carry all the damn ticks
as well.
Oh, this fatty is outside eating my
apples.
He gets up close enough to the tree
right in trees that I have, then I'm
going to go out there and I'm going to
get him.
I don't need a license to show them off,
though.
could probably go run up the deer.
That'd be a fun thing to do.
Who wins? Me or the deer? Two to one
odds in my favor.
Okay, this looks better to me.
This looks like a actual battle sib
But the thing is, humans can only do
that if they're trained.
You can't do it if you're not trained.
like lazy couch potato human suck at
running. I'm moderately trained.
Like humans can get really good at
running.
Like if you run, you kind of have to run
for like two hours a day though at
least.
What's the workout nutri routine and
nutrition?
Well, at the moment I have like a bad
shoulder and a bad knee, but I usually
do like a combo of just uh a combo of
distance running and uh powerlifting
stuff.
But at the moment, pretty much all I can
do are pull-ups, deadlifts, and some
accessory stuff. And maybe one run a
week, some biking and rowing. I've been
switching it up a bit. Once my knee is
back, I'm going to go back to training
for
probably short distance, probably
training for like a decent 5K.
And then I've been wanting to get my
overhead press to be quite strong. And I
was doing well on that until shoulder.
It was lightweight. I was pressing like
six. I was shoulder pressing like 60s
and like some guys came like some guys
came by and like like basically
interrupted me and threw me off.
I like I dropped it at like a weird
angle like I just jerked my shoulder
back a bit.
Caroline fracture running is rough.
Yeah, I just have um I think it's
patella tend patella patellar tendinitis
on my right one and I just don't want to
tear it. So, I've been taking it easy.
Too many roads. Was running too many
roads in Florida.
I have a good diet. I mean, it's just
it's pretty much just all whole foods
with enough protein.
Nothing special.
I mean, I eat like a lot of really
calorie dense stuff. I eat like a lot of
really heavy stuff just because I don't
have the appetite otherwise. I have a
pretty low appetite.
Okay, I'm trying to think if there's
anything else I can do on this
environment tonight or if I should just
call it early.
I think it's going to be kind of an
ordeal to get into
into what we need to do next on this.
If I have
impulse decent. Yeah, let's take a look
at your policy, Captain, and then I'll
call it early. I think that's what we'll
do.
I don't know. Unless folks have cool RL
questions or want to like know how to
get involved with stuff. I've been kind
of burnt because I've been just working
a lot on this release. Um, I kind of
want to get a nice start early tomorrow
on the drone environment for the most
part. I guess I also have stuff to do
for meta.
Been meaning to do that. I could set
them up some experiments.
I might do that after I look at
Captain's thing. Here, Captain. Where
where should I look at this policy?
So, what did you do different? Did you
just like run it on the new thing and
have it work?
This is just a that guy is a man. Like
don't listen don't pay too much
attention.
Just trained on 3. That's what I like to
hear.
That pretty much validates 300 on
everything, right?
Yeah. I don't know. It's I pretty much
just hate the way big like big tech
engineering does everything. Um
I just I can't work with it. It's just
[ __ ]
Like they still get work done sometimes,
but
that's a decent like that's playing the
game.
It's got like the mechanics to like not
die
even if it's like
Hey, Captain. Is there any one hot data
in here?
Like is there one hot data in the uh
hang on let me go look at your policy.
But is there one hot in here?
Oh yeah, there is.
This is no longer a function
for this.
Okay. So, you trained 300k
23% end of time. It looked like
2.9 4 mil per
Okay. What are the uh
defaults? 100 million.
I asked what you earned your PhD in.
Massively multi-agent reinforcement
learning. Uh I worked on getting
reinforcement learning working in
scenarios with like a thousand agents.
Now I work on general purpose
reinforcement learning including that.
It all works much much faster.
Hey captain, this linear LSTM policy is
kind of training.
Have you actually tried just running it
for like 1.5 bill maybe with like one
hot encoded data?
Cuz like you won't have to code a C
policy if you can just get something
decent with uh linear LSTM for the
website.
Okay.
Well, well, I mean, if you want the
simple version of it, it's train AI. You
train a thousand agents to play the same
game together
with AI.
There, this is a followup to my PhD.
It's lagging a little bit because I also
have AI training on my uh on my PC for
something else right now. But um this is
uh an agent in an environment with like
a thousand other agents
and it plays this like simple MMO and I
didn't tell it anything about this game.
It kind of just figured it all out
itself.
This combines like high performance
simulation.
What's going on here?
Uh, this stuff combines like high
performance simulation
with the reinforcement learning, whole
bunch of infrastructure, other things.
Let me close this because
interrupting our training
sitting duck off the matches are
actually interesting.
should do some sort of curriculum
learning thing. I think captain,
I have no idea if this will actually do
well if you train it for longer, but I
don't know. It's probably worth trying
to just train a simple policy.
You're at all familiar with Python?
Well, yes, of course.
You literally didn't program two years
ago.
Everybody's got to learn
This probably is not going to be very
good.
It just like doesn't know how to move
well, right?
It like end up shooting itself.
Yeah. It like it doesn't know what to do
with the weapons either.
Oh, it doesn't know to hold the rail gun
to charge it.
Yeah, this is just like a like a very
early policy as all.
I would like to just run this thing with
way larger batch size, but like ENVA is
going to cap out on course.
Mind blown. Didn't realize latest worked
like that.
Better with deterministic. Yeah,
I mean that's what I've been working on
for months. Captain
against a scripted bot.
How do I do that?
I mean, this is just more confirmation
though that um like the new update
pretty much does exactly what it's
supposed to. It's just better
reinforcement learning, right?
Let me see if I can figure something out
for the meta guys real quick. You know,
the thing is it's not a quick project at
all
because the code's like
Go. Glad I stumbled across channel.
Watch YouTube. Yeah, I would suggest
there's my thesis and then there's also
the RL iceberg which is like an
explainer video that I made with overall
overview of a lot of things I'm thinking
about in RL.
I don't have much steam in me left to do
this tonight. Um,
think
release is pretty well good to go. I
have trailer to do, maybe some articles
to edit, not much else.
Pretty much everything else is good to
go.
Uh, and it's time to start working on
more interesting stuff. So, I think
tomorrow we'll do What's your channel?
Can't find it. Neuralarmm. I'll show
you. I probably should rebrand that
channel, but
if you just look up my name, you'll see
it as well. Just as far as these events.
Here you go. Okay, so it'll show up. It
has some views on it.
How's trailer looking? Well, it's not
looking yet, right? It's uh editors
getting to it. Um, but I found I found a
few different editors and uh one of whom
looks quite good. So hopefully we have
something there.
Good job on policy, Captain. Um, be cool
to throw it on the website if we could,
but I I also don't like porting
something like that to see as a total
pain in the ass. So
I don't know. Maybe just like see if you
can get the linear one to do something.
If you just like one hop the obs,
usually linear does something decent
Also fine to just keep working on like
training better policies. If it doesn't
saturate after 1.5 bill, you know, like
you could probably just do it like a mix
of scripted, like a mix of sitting duck
and the other one and just like train it
for 100 bill
have scripted bots. We could I think it
would be better to like have it be you
versus scripted bot or something
because, you know, if we just put them
both as scripted bots, it'll look like,
oh yeah, it's the neural net when it's
not.
Don't really want to do that.
talk tomorrow. Yeah, I think
today is today was Wednesday.
Tomorrow's Thursday. I think tomorrow
I'll see if I can actually have some fun
on the drone environment and make
something really cool out of it. Um,
and then Friday I'll probably like
actually do the release and just not
tell anybody.
And then like all the stuff will go live
on Monday.
We have a fair few folks on Twitch and
YouTube, but um I'm pretty much gassed
for the evening. So, I'll be back on
probably pretty early tomorrow in the
morning. And uh yeah, we will work on
the large scale battle environment.
We'll see how much crazy stuff I do on
that. I think we probably can like I
have some ideas on how to just make that
thing pretty pretty darn cool. Um I need
to be fresh for that though. Then Friday
we'll probably do release stuff. We'll
also do meta things because I owe the
meta guys a bunch of work and yeah,
we'll go from there. So thanks for
tuning in. Um all this stuff is free and
open source. You can read more about it
on puffer.ai.
And if you want to get involved with
reinforcement learning dev, you want to
learn or you already know some stuff and
you want to contribute either way,
join the Discord. We have lots of brand
new people in there that are already
like building some pretty awesome stuff.
So yeah, that start the uh Yep. start
the GitHub, follow on X, all the things.
I'll be back when I'm refreshed.